just north of ontario's largest city
sets an equestrian oasis a little farm a
stone's throw from lake simcoe
it's here diane van kulin finds comfort
and an escape from what she's facing
the 61 year old has stage 4 lung cancer
i remember seeing the x-ray on the on
the screen in the er room thinking that
better not be mine
being diagnosed with stage 4 lung cancer
was such an overwhelming diagnosis it
took me time to process it
the cancer had spread to her lymph nodes
ribs and spine
she was getting treatment and then the
pandemic hit
diane started feeling sicker and sicker
but the idea of going to a hospital for
care
the fear of getting kovid 19 it was too
much
she delayed going and unbeknownst to her
the cancer treatment
wasn't working the result some of
diane's
tumors tripled in size i was my own
worst enemy i refused to go in for four
weeks and my body became
more broken what would have happened if
i went in
at the beginning would i be at less risk
of progression
diane's story and stories like hers have
doctors deeply concerned
all aspects of cancer care from
diagnosis to treatment
are being impacted by covet 19. when you
say that kovit has had a profound
implication on the delivery of cancer
care
this is big dr lucy gilbert is the
director of gynecological oncology at
mcgill university health center in
montreal
she says one of the harshest realities
of the pandemic
finding out you have cancer then being
told your care might be postponed
it's heartbreaking and you wonder
do i want to continue in this position
because in a way i feel you are
party to a crime
we are the ones who will deal with the
patients
who are petrified who are afraid who
know cancer will not wait
according to the canadian institute for
health information from march to june
2020
cancer surgeries were down 20 across the
country
some hospitals were able to catch up but
the third wave has put
all that in jeopardy many surgeries even
cancer surgeries deemed urgent have once
again
been put on hold and some oncologists
like dr gilbert
have to meet with committees every week
to decide who's sick enough to get a
surgical spot
we have to present the patients who we
think are
very sick and who if we do not give them
a date within three to four weeks
will come to severe harm it's almost
a bit like a lottery i am competing
with say the vascular surgeons who say
the patient may lose a limb or the eye
surgeon who says the patient will become
blind and that's not a way
we want to run a health care system
but this is what we do now
how many surgeries have been postponed
would you say
yeah it's in the thousands if we're
talking about all surgeries
it's gonna soon hit over a hundred
thousand like it's like it's a
astronomical number dr antoine iskander
is a surgical oncologist at sunnybrook
health sciences center in toronto
he's been collecting data on new
diagnoses oncology surgeries
and screening tests being done during
the pandemic
we saw a 60 drop in cancer directed
surgeries
on the week of march 15 of 2020 in
ontario
and subsequent to that over the next few
months we had an increase in the amount
of surgery but we never hit
pre-pandemic rates of cancer surgery
but the true magnitude of the problem
won't be told for some
time it'll take a year two years because
there's patients we haven't even heard
about
that should be in the system but aren't
even on the wait list yet
that's because some people are not
getting screened so many would-be cancer
patients
haven't been diagnosed yet you wonder
where some of these cancers are
some of them are missing in action we
don't know where they are we've seen a
drop
in cancer incidence rates despite
there being a very steady rate of
cancers being diagnosed in ontario over
the last 10 years
and that's very worrisome physicians say
when people
finally seek care their cancers are far
worse than if they had come in when they
first had symptoms
if you get these cancers in stage one
the cure rate
exceeds 1995
but we are seeing much more patients
in what we call advanced unresectable
stages
and once it becomes stage four its
cure is almost impossible
a recent u.s study found nearly 10
million cancer screenings failed to
happen in 2020
alone because of covin here at home
data is still being collected so it's
impossible to know how many people will
be impacted
people are so frightened of going
and seeing doctors the likelihood of
catching covet from a health care
facilities
is minuscule because we are obsessional
about following their rules
so please please report problems in time
have your tests in time
for some canadians who are sick enough
to get immediate cancer care during the
pandemic
there have been tough decisions
[Music]
more than a year ago don pickering's
seven-year-old son oliver
had what looked like a small bump on his
neck it turned out to be anaplastic
large cell lymphoma
a rare form of blood cancer to survive
oliver needed a stem cell transplant his
health team
in ottawa turned to the donation
registry for help
so you can imagine you know our shock
and our concern
but they found three perfect matches so
we really felt like we had won the
lottery which was pretty incredible
sadly the relief was short-lived at this
time the pandemic was declared and the
country went into lockdown
oliver's matches were international and
because of travel restrictions and covet
19 concerns
they weren't able to donate he just
moved his fingers
with limited options the family had to
ask their 11 year old daughter abby who
was a half match
and then i came home and then my mom was
there
and she goes so we have some news
and then at that moment i was just like
oh my goodness oh my goodness oh my
goodness
and then she told me that we needed
knee for the stem cells and i was like
okay well i just thought of all the
scenarios and i thought like my brother
was gonna die
so that's better than him dying at least
he has a chance to live
[Music]
when we found out that we were going to
have to use our daughter's stem cells
for me that certainly stressed me out
quite a bit
because now i have not just one sick
child but a second child who i have to
make sure is protected
and that nothing happens to her and she
doesn't get covered
it was a risk the family was forced to
take i
still can't believe that i'm gonna do it
then i'm going to do stem cells
after many painful procedures and lots
of covered safety precautions
abby was able to donate you know
we'll get through this and it'll be okay
so i'm just going to stay here
i was like if this was ollie he would
definitely do it for me because my
brother is a very
kind compassionate empathetic guy and
he's
always been there for me your sister
she was the one who gave you her stem
cells how did that feel
she was really kind to me and now since
i'm well we go back to
brother and sister sibling fights
okay ready rock paper scissors shoot
[Laughter]
how is oliver doing now he's doing
fantastic actually i'm really
pleased to tell you that he's very well
daily he shocks us with what he can do
and
how quickly he manages to to recover
from all the things that have happened
to you
laser laser cuts rock in half
oliver was one of the lucky ones others
haven't been so fortunate
experts say with the current state of
cancer care we're just trading one
health crisis
for another it's been described as
there's going to be a tsunami of cancer
cases after we get out of this copic
crisis
i don't disagree with that i think there
will be an uptick
of identifying these patients that have
not been diagnosed yet
but the question is are we going to
identify them at a point where there's
very little we can do
that's what scares us i would gladly
take a tsunami
of patients that needed treatment and
sorting out how we would do that
over patients who we've missed who now
can't get treatment
and we just don't know yet how that's
going to pan out
it's so interesting that you're saying a
backlogger tsunami would be actually a
good thing
compared to what you think could
potentially happen exactly
i would almost welcome a tsunami because
i think we would find a way
to make it work we'd have to be very
creative and very
thoughtful and we'd have to try a few
new things
but we would probably find a way to make
it work
as for diane van kulin she's had several
rounds of treatment and is now
on a new cancer drug i hope this drug
just keeps working for a long long time
because i have a lot of things i want to
do still
in my life so far she's feeling stronger
she's even gotten back up on her horse
but diane hopes her story can serve as a
cautionary tale for those
avoiding care i'm trying to be
respectful of people's
fear right but what i've learned is fear
gets you nowhere
and if you have that opportunity to go
to an er
if you have the opportunity to get
treated that day
don't wait four weeks cancer can grow
you know you've got to weigh the
benefits the pros and cons and they're
definitely in my case were far more
cons for waiting as long as i did learn
my lesson